it's my birthday and I and I got the
blues man I I I don't like
birthdays and um and and it didn't even
have to be my birthday I was already
struggling why don't you like your
birthday I thought you were upset
because we didn't text you on your
birthday no no no no like that's my
number one thing is that I there's a lot
of things it's not number one I don't
like how I got to battle through
hundreds of text messages you know it's
just annoying like uh I had just
bombarded that was my whole morning just
oh thank you so much yeah yeah yeah
really appreciate it yeah I love you you
know like for somebody that loves
attention so much that's kind of like
that's surprising it's it's true yeah it
it's true at what age did you start
hating your birthdays
26 he knows it on the 100% 26 I remember
uh
25 I was uh working in nightclubs as a
circus clown just getting drunk and
lighting myself on fire doing fire
breathing backflips in this
nightclub and uh I got fired for getting
too drunk but um I got the job on cruise
ships I was stoked I was celebrating the
next year 26 I'm working in the
circus and I showed up to work
everybody's there like the
whole uh day I did not tell one person
that it was was my birthday because I
was bummed that I was
26 why what's 26 yeah cuz that's old
like I mean it was it was older than I
cared to be and and uh and it it was
just all downhill from there you know
I'm 26 25 was cool but 26 is Step too
far I mean this sort of like the end of
like some sort of childhood like no one
says like ah you're young when you're 26
at 25 they sort of say that still but
like yeah they do everybody everybody
who's older than 26 says Ah you're young
young I mean now like I'm 49 it's it's a
straight bummer you know like and every
year my birthday just makes me a whole
year older it's this annoying day that
makes you an entire year older when you
don't want to be older and people bug
you with texts all
day and what else but isn't it like
a isn't it like a blessing because you
didn't think you're going to live past
30 anyway so like you're like dude I'm
[__] plus you know sure sure now like
I can I can talk about some positives
too about how getting older when you go
through life and you manage to learn
from your mistakes and make appropriate
adjustments
to overcome and and and whatever you
know like what ends up happening is you
you kind of get better at the art of
living and and and I can't help even
though this just probably sounds douchy
and arrogant but I genuinely feel that
I've
gotten a lot better at living and and
when you get better at life it really
takes a lot of the the pain out of
getting older it's like yeah I'm older
but I'm better and I do feel like like
I'm better in a lot of ways so there's
that but why I've been struggling and
then doesn't have anything to do with uh
with my birthday this has been going on
um like you going to bring it up I I
don't know what you're talking about no
like um I I I don't know what you're
talking about what I'm talking about is
uh this Dynamic that I've started seeing
happen on my social media when I'm
posting on social
media I want to post like what's going
to crush you know I want all this is
going to be Banger it's going to crush
and I'm posting like you know like
gnarly stunts like jackass Clips you
know like and
uh and I don't want to post just like
like like what's going on with me and
where I'm at you know because like
what's going on with me and where I'm at
isn't like super exciting it's not
something that's going to totally Crush
I just can't bring myself to post
something where I'm just sitting there
you know like you know like like
whatever happens to be going on I want
it to be some kind of like super
highlevel crazy thing but then the like
I just see that that on social
media what I'm posting is just kind of
not representative of who I am you know
like and uh I was really conflicted
about like when I when I like twice I've
posted me getting choked unconscious
and uh you know with Michael bis being
in the Octagon there's something super
official about that and it got all this
press and I was and I was stoked but in
the back of my mind too I'm like like
you know I I know Jeff Tain and noxville
just hate that so much like uh what they
out they hate seeing me get choked out
they hate the idea of uh putting that
out there as something that's cool you
know like uh okay you know it's just
like they think it's dark well why did
you put it out there because I thought
it would
crush and it did not only did it crush
it got picked up by Sports Illustrated
so many outlets like the Daily Mail TMZ
you getting choked out by m but not by
Michael bisbing by Michael bisbing yeah
yeah I'm talking about the one where you
got choked out six times right and then
that's the thing is that it was like a
couple weeks ago I posted Michael
bisbing but then I'm like I I want to
promote the my upcoming UK tour so like
like what what footage do I have from
the UK that like that's a tie in you
know where I can and I was like oh dude
I'll post the getting choked out six
times and dude I went back and deleted
that I don't know I don't know if you
noticed that I went back and deleted it
for two reasons one I thought um like it
was just like a community guidelines
violation waiting to happen I mean can
we even like touch on how ridiculous it
is that if post even the most slightly
underdressed and not sexual but like
scantly you know like anything even
remotely half naked with Lux boom like
they're so sensitive about all platforms
yeah it's ridiculous but that surprised
me cuz I see like super hot chicks
wearing almost nothing like all the time
on Instagram yeah I don't know I don't
know maybe it's I'm under a spotlight I
I think I know what the reason why the
the all the platforms got so sensitive
about sexuality is because uh of what
was in that PornHub documentary did you
guys watch that uh I did yeah the the
documentary on Netflix look at his hat
no shitty watch the PornHub
documentary Vinnie's over there wearing
a brazzers's hat um the uh the the
PornHub doc it was crazy like the the
law used to be that um like Faceook
whatever like that that that that none
of these platforms were responsible for
what got posted on them because they're
not media platforms they're just uh like
servers you know so they're like hey man
we're just a platform where people can
put stuff up we're not responsible for
what people put up and that kind of
makes sense you know to an extent but
with PornHub they were like people were
uploading like criminal stuff you know
there was like like n non consensual
stuff there was like stuff with miners
you know like and and and their
pornhub's taking the position hey man
we're just a platform where people
upload stuff we're not responsible for
what gets uploaded so now they can get
in trouble now now then a lot changed
not too long ago where they put their
foot down and they were like yo like you
are responsible for any like
particularly around sex stuff can we so
so like anything remotely sexy boom
taken down but I post being violently
strangled unconscious and thrown onto my
head six times in a row and it's totally
cool with Instagram yeah do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole Plus steo
butthole destroyer and sto's butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude